So, whether or not you're a fan, I'm sure that
you've heard this song and today we're going to
be learning English with it along with two more
of The Weeknd hits! Be warned his songs include
vulgar language and topics like drugs so if
you are sensitive to these then you might
want to check out a more family-friendly
lesson by cleaning up here. And by the way,
if you are new here every single week we
help you to understand your favorite movies,
series, songs and more without getting
lost, without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles. Like Hilola who said that
our lessons helped them increase their IELTS score
so we'll help you to reach your
English learning goals too. Just
hit that subscribe button and the bell below
so you won't miss any of our new lessons!
While in careful speech this would be "out of
your league," when we use rapid speech it becomes
"ou-duh-yur league." Let's see a couple more
examples of this common case of connected speech!
All right, so now let's move on to The Weeknd's
next hit which has been rated as the most popular
song of 2020 globally! Real quick though, I have
a question: do you get frustrated when natives
speak really fast? Well I want to help. That's
why we created this Master Class that will help
you to understand natives no matter how fast we
speak, by learning the vocabulary that natives
really use every day, pronunciation, how we cut
and connect our words together, understanding all
of the jokes by learning about the culture. And
it's absolutely free! You will not find it here
on youtube so you can learn more and sign up by
going up here or down in the description below.
If you're loving learning with The Weeknd
songs then don't stop now! Over on our
Instagram at reallife.english you will find
a lesson with another one of his hit songs.
Plus every day you can get more fun and
fast lessons with your favorite movies,
series and more! Now, let's learn with
the final song "I can't feel my face."
Have you been enjoying learning with The Weeknd?
Then next I recommend you learn with another music
lesson like the recent one that we created
with Dua Lipa or tons more that we have in
this playlist of lessons with songs. You'll
find that by clicking up here or down in the
description below. Now, let's wrap up today's
lesson by testing everything you've learned!